expertise du paléontologue n'est pas
souvent demandé alors qu'en ce moment on
ne parle que du jurassique world
jurassic park 4 si vous préférez c'est
quand une occase pour les paléontologues
de faire entendre leur voix et cette
voie elle n'est pas anodine
la levée de boucliers des fans contre
l'idée de potentiel raptor apprivoiser
dans le film nous le montre bien
pourquoi parce que si le concept des
dinosaures que nous vendait le film
était correcte les gens n'auraient aucun
problème à s'imaginer qu'à carnivores ça
peut être autre chose qu'une espèce de
créature assoiffée de sang qui ne vit
que pour tuer et se rappellerait que les
rapaces des fauconniers sont des
dinosaures carnivores apprivoiser du
reste des chiens et les chats que vous
chérissez temps sont aussi les
carnivores
alors merci au cinéma de ne pas oublier
une fois de plus que manger de la viande
ne fait pas automatiquement de vous
quelqu'un de méchant cruel et assoiffé
de sang
parmi les nombreuses casquettes que
porte le paléontologue en tant que
biologiste il vous l'aurait dit et là on
en vient à notre sujet principal la
science de la vie pétrifié dans la roche
la paléontologie un fossile ce n'est pas
un simple objet de décoration c'est la
trace qu'un être autrefois vivant il ya
plusieurs milliers voire même millions
d'années a laissé sur notre terre et
rien que pour ça la paléontologie comme
disent les américains c'est ma is et ce
en paléontologie
celui-ci pas d'origine et notre espace
pas de dinosaures pas de jurassic park
non mais attendez vous vous imaginez
votre enfant ce sens à la paléontologie
mais pour parfaitement à tous les gens
qui se posent la question peut-on encore
rêver dans ce monde si ce scientifique
ceux qui connaissent c'est facile ça
bien qu'il n'y a pas besoin de
s'inventer des monstres et des mythes
quand on sait la réalité la diversité et
la beauté des mondes disparus
oui et est bien mignonne avec des
gadgets mais enfin a pas à faire des
musées des documentaires et des films la
paléontologie excuse moi mais ça sert à
rien ça rapporte rien du tout même pas
d'argent et puis les connaissances que
ça à mai
voici en vivre sans ouais ok il ya des
gros lézard qui ont vécu sur terre et
qui ont disparu il ya trois mille ans la
belle affaire où tout le monde s'en tape
del mentalité je vois mais à bien y
réfléchir vous allez me dire ce qui a
vraiment l'utilité dans ce bas-monde
faire régner la loi et l'ordre
ça a l'air important peut-être aurais-je
dû préciser faire régner la loi des
hommes parce qu'en dehors de notre
planète et du cadre éphémère de notre
civilisation
l'univers ils s'en balancent de nos
petites affaires à soigner les gens
c'est important a retardé ce qui serait
inévitable oui ça c'est important
et après leur trépas qu'est ce qu'ils
diront tous ces gens des facile vous
voyez d'une façon ou d'une autre tout en
revient à la paléontologie
évidemment nous n'appelons pas à
l'anarchie nous voulons simplement
expliqué que petit jeu cynique du quai
ce qui est vraiment utile
la paléontologie n'est pas plus mal
classés que n'importe quelle autre
activité humaine et c'est oublier que
dans le cadre plus restreint de notre
société occidentale la paléontologie ne
se limite pas qu'à un apport de
connaissances brut et sans intérêt
immédiat
le paléontologue eric buffetaut nous
l'expliquent bien dans son livre à quoi
servent les dinosaures les applications
la paléontologie sont multiples
connaître des fossiles c'est connaître
la roche qui forment notre terroir et
nourrit nos produits elle aide aussi à
la recherche des strates géologiques
recelant des ressources naturelles dont
nous avons besoin comme le pétrole ou
tout simplement l'eau et comme toute
science historique la paléontologie nous
informent sur notre passé pour mieux
comprendre et anticiper les évènements
de demain nous mêmes sur notre chaîne
avons déjà disserter sur la porte de la
paléontologie à deux débats on ne peut
plus d'actualité
le gaz de schiste et le réchauffement
climatique la paléontologie s'inscrit en
plus dans un cadre plus large celui des
sciences de l'évolution quelqu'un qui ne
comprend pas comment fonctionne
l'évolution des espèces ne peut pas
comprendre comment certains insectes
évoluent et deviennent résistantes aux
pesticides commander dose trop forte
d'antibiotiques finissent par donner
davantage à des souche résistante de
bactérie tueuse ou bien tout simplement
comment fonctionnent les gènes de
l'homme sachant qu'ils n'ont jamais
cessé d'évoluer
le premier a des implications directes
sur la gestion de l'agriculture et de
nos ressources et en tenir compte
pourrait à terme conduire à moins de
pesticides et moins de gm le deuxième et
le troisième en une répercussion directe
sur notre santé alors résumons nous les
implications directes ou indirectes de
la paléontologie étendent leur réseau
tentaculaire dans tous ses éléments de
votre quotidien pétrole eau nourriture
sa rareté et vous ça vous suffit où il
vous en faut plus mais se demander à
quoi sert la paléontologie cache une
interrogation bien plus profonde et
perverse
la question est de savoir si toutes ces
sciences à première vue inutiles celles
qui ne conduisent à l'invention d'aucun
médicament ou bien au dépôt odp aucun
brevet ont un quelconque intérêt
la théorie de l'évolution de par son
apparente simplicité c'est partie des
premières qu'on a voulu qualifier de
sans intérêt personne ou si peu n'ose
remettre en question l'idée que la terre
tourne autour du soleil n'ont par contre
des gens qui vous diront que l'évolution
mois l'évolution moins bon mais faut
savoir garder l'esprit ouvert quoi il ya
quand même quelque chose d'autre quoi ça
vous en trouverez plein il y en a même
certainement pas renié vous on a tous un
petit créationnistes dans la tête qui
sait un jour dit que la nature a été
trop bien fait pour être apparu tout
seul mais pensez y un instant
croyez-vous qu'une espèce qui n'aurait
pas su trouver sa place dans le monde au
fil des millions d'années survivre est
suffisamment longtemps pour que vous
puissiez ne pas vous étonner rang comme
la nature est bien faite
évidemment non et qu'est ce qui vous le
dit la raison n'est de votre éducation
de par leur inutilité apparente ces
sciences de l'évolution qui ne
produisent ni richesse ni bénéfices
directs paléontologie en tête sont le
thermomètre de la santé intellectuelle
d'une nation est le premier rempart
contre le retour d'un obscurantisme pia
moyenâgeux leur principal but est la
production de savoirs brut celui qui à
grand peine finira par arriver dans les
livres d'école
ce savoir est fondamental car c'est lui
qui forme les futures générations
imaginez une nation ou de savoir pour le
savoir n'existerait plus on en
apprendrait plus que des choses
rentabilise abl ce serait la fin de la
curiosité la fin de l'esprit critique
celle de la pensée des lumières de
l'encyclopédie ce serait la porte
ouverte à l'ignorance puis à la
superstition au fanatisme et en face
la fin de notre liberté la fin du la
démocratie la démocratie monsieur la
démocratie taxant les pentes de dire
savoir c'est comprendre comprendre la
démocratie alors souhaité par la
paléontologie vous ne soutenez pas
simplement les chercheurs ou même les
enseignants non vous soutenez la
république
alors vive la république vive la
paléontologie et vive la science
bien franchement humblement que si on
n'est pas allé un peu loin la personne
va y croire à ce délire genre les
fossiles les dinosaures la démocratie
tout sa tête a traité sur l'impasse que
mon passé c'est des trucs de gamme aqua
la paléontologie moi j'ai arrêté de
jouer avec mes dinosaures quand la
limite en limitant c'est bien ça les
huit ans alors ça veut dire qu'à bâle et
on te donne en fait son boulot c'est ton
rêve de gosse commenge les quatre serres